hands up guys my name is a cello and
welcome to the second episode of the
sterilization mini-series which I'm sure
that you all are enjoying so today in
this second episode we will be talking
about the actual format of our binary
file okay so obviously the last time we
talked about what sir ization was and we
covered kind of what we needed to do to
achieve that and why we were doing that
and whatnot
a few questions arose from all that and
I did see some comments and a lot of the
comments were like well first of all a
lot of you guys seem very interested in
this oh that's great
but then I saw some comments which were
like why are we doing this why aren't we
just using Java sterilization okay and
that's a very good question and the
reason we're not using Java
sterilization is for actually two
primary reasons okay the first reason is
that it's actually quite slow right Java
sterilization is very old they've
certainly been improving it with each
new version of Java but still it's it's
very older of course they can't kind of
change the course structure of it
because then and that they would lose
support for older versions of the JDK
and whatnot and there's this whole kind
of compatibility issue but when they
first wrote it it was it wasn't really
written very efficiently unfortunately
and usually what happens is when when
Java API is get written performance is
not kind of their top priority it never
isn't and in fact that they're more or
less really concerned with compatibility
really concerned with a nice to use kind
of API even though I in my opinion they
kind of fail on that a number of times
and there are there certainly kind of
very concerned with compatibility
between platforms as well because
remember Java has to be the same across
all platforms and and all that stuff so
unfortunately that is bad for kind of
high performance applications which is
why not many people use java web
performance is important okay and what
are they using it just because the game
programming series and also I think that
in some ways this is more simple in Java
it to be honest serialization is
probably more complicated but we'll get
onto that and you'll see what I mean
because as we start actually writing
code I will be pointing out things like
oh hey you know if we would if we did
this in like said
we would do this instead and it would be
better or worse and I'll kind of mention
that in passing comments and everything
will be fine but that's one of the
reasons the other the only reason that
it's actually slow though the whole Java
object output streams object input
stream is all destroyed - and stuff is
for a number of reasons if you actually
take a look at the code you'll see that
there's a lot of temporary object
allocation which means that they're
making unnecessary objects all the time
the actual input output stream is very
slow and then remember that one of the
ways that it actually is able to
automate itself and why don't think we
spoke too much about automation last
time and I feel that's another thing we
should cover and by automation all I
mean is like kind of ease of use in
terms of API so rather than having to be
like hey take a look at this entity it
has these fields I want you to serialize
these fields they are this type you know
all of that stuff that's kind of very
big burst and it requires ask kind of on
the game side to actually specify a lot
of things whereas what you could do with
Java theoretically is do something like
oh hey here's an interesting object
serialize it right and the serialization
library could have zero information
about how that object of what that
object is like for example in the thing
that we used last time we saw we saw
that entity for example had a name XY
and like an inventory or whatever we
know that because we wrote it right but
when we give it to Java like Java
doesn't really know its structure
however Java can find out what its
structure is via a process called
reflection okay so it can basically
check out the compile time information
that's given for the object and at
runtime essentially query it for its
actual structure now as good as that
sounds it's actually very slow okay and
it makes sense that it's slow because
this kind of information isn't something
that you technically want to store when
you when you're when you're when your
application gets compiled right and into
an able reflection and to be able to
actually query it from information that
isn't normally supposed to be there is a
big problem all right in C++ we could
have
like it's in C++ you can do this thing
where essentially if we had a struct for
example I don't wanna get too off-topic
but if we had a struct that was entity
and we had let's just say in a struct we
had something like we had an accent of Y
and there were both integers right and
then we had maybe like a bull for
whether or not the entity is still alive
like a removed kind of situation if we
had something like that we could
actually sterilize that as I kind of did
the other thing or at the type in the
brackets here and then R at the name of
the rice here anyway point is we could
do something like if we had an instance
of that entity somewhere over here in
our code we could actually get all of
the bytes as you can see the size of the
entity in this case would be local
that'd be 9 bytes right so we could do
something like take the memory address
of of e essentially and then basically
put that into a byte array that would be
like a char and unsigned char array that
is ray right that is essentially 9 this
syntax isn't correct but the point is we
could essentially do something like that
right and we would have to cast that to
Achara whatever but the point is we can
get that because in C++ we can just
basically be like hey what is the
starting address of the HG object and I
know that obviously in memory this is
gonna be stored in a row so you will
have your X variable you'll have your Y
variable right next to it and then
you'll have your removed thing right and
I know I can just grab that entire chunk
and serialize it as a bunch of bytes
because it already already been by its
because I've got that direct memory
access and whatnot and then I can put it
back into place where I meet when I need
to okay so you can do stuff like that
you can only do that in Java but you do
have reflection and whatnot okay and
obviously this system would break as
soon as you have something like a string
because then you would have to go into
that address and it's gonna get very
messy and this kind of automation is I
mean you wouldn't typically do anyway
but the point is you could do stuff with
reflection and that is how the Java
sterilization works for the most part if
you want if you want like an easy way to
do it but unfortunately yeah that is
slow and work
looking for some things fast anyway
that's the first major reason I feel
like I've spent way too much time on
that in fact it's been like seven
minutes really what maybe that's
ridiculous
anyway um we're gonna get on to the
format I promise um so that's the first
reason okay we don't want to use Java
striation because it's not very it's not
very good okay
the second big thing and this is almost
normal almost bigger because even if
Java sting was very good we would still
be doing this and the reason is it is a
learning experience okay this whole game
programming series this whole channel
really is devoted to teaching you guys
how to do something scratch that's
always been kind of my passion and what
I like doing but it's also what this
channel is here for right if you want to
learn how to use an existing API you
should really just read the
documentation it's not that scary it's
pretty simple and it makes a lot of
sense right but this stuff is stuff that
it will take you if you were to learn
this yourself it would take a lot of
time right which is why I'm here to kind
of help you guys out and and make videos
on stuff that probably isn't that
readily available for you online okay
obviously there are tons of tutorials on
how to make a sterilization library but
the point is this is kind of what this
channel is about right so I'm teaching
you guys how to do this stuff from
scratch that's what the game programming
series is all about and and that's
actually what the rest is channel is
pretty much about okay so we're learning
how to do this because it's a useful
learning experience okay cool
that's pretty much it so that's without
further ado let's just move on to the
format because I don't want to split
this up into more videos so we need to
think about the format now that's kind
of where we're up to you right now and I
don't know why I just lost my paintbrush
alright format so as I mentioned before
we're going to be writing out a bunch of
bytes okay so it's important for us
right now to decide which bytes mean
what okay because the bytes that we
write out I just gonna be they're just
gonna be that right they're just gonna
be bytes we have no idea what they mean
we have no idea what we have no idea how
to interpret them right they're just a
bunch of bytes okay
we need a format so that we can be like
oh okay I expect the first two bytes of
the file to mean this then the next part
might mean this and then maybe ten bytes
in we start this and etc right that's
kind of the idea so when you look at
when you look at the format's in file
formats in general they usually have
something called a header and sometimes
you might see a footer okay and then in
between is kind of where your data lies
all right so the header is the header
does a few things okay usually the
header would identify the file type so
it'll be like oh hey I'm an mp4 I'm an
mp4 file or I'm a Word document or
something like that right the reason
that is there for a few reasons is first
of all it's a very quick sanity check to
just be like okay I'm reading I'm
reading the right file so for example we
might have a header that might say
something like Cherno okay just for
example I don't think it will in our
format but we might have like the first
few bytes of the file might say check
okay that way we know that this is a
tournament file pretty easily we just
have to scan the first six bytes in this
case there's six characters we scan the
first things bytes if they're equal to
show no great the file is probably valid
it might not be obviously but for all
intents purposes right now for us yeah
it's possibly valid right it's a good
it's a good first step basically and
then typically you might have something
like a version number as well to be like
hey this is like version 0.1 of the
sterilisation format so that if you for
example be the reason the reason we do
that normally is just so that you can
because formats might change in the
future that's kind of the reason right
so if you drastically change your format
around version 0.5 for example right if
you were to do that then you would but
you might break compatibility with these
formats but what you can do ultimately
is you can actually check the file when
you open it to start deserializing and
start reading it you might open the file
and be like hey what those are you au
0.1 or au 0.5 and above for example and
if you were 0.5 and above I might use
this data structure to digitalize you
otherwise if you're below 0.5 I might
use the old legacy kind of
for Matt to digitalize you right and
that way you can support a lot of
versions of one mob but it's important
to know what version it is so usually
the version would be something that you
keep there and that's and then in the
header as well it's very common to have
a bunch of flags maybe the name of the
actual file or something as well some
people do that just because it might get
renamed or something so if you have like
a we'll talk more about this in a minute
but um you might have certain properties
and whatnot that you want to set for
example like an mp4 file might have like
a the width and height in pixels of the
actual like the resolution of the video
what what frames per second it's
supposed to run out right all of that
kind of stuff metadata as well as
something that you might have you might
you wouldn't typically have that in the
header per se the head is really there
just to kind of address these kind of
issues like hey this is this file this
is this version this is it kind of
provides you with it provides the
deserialize err almost with just a bunch
of information on how to digitize this
file it'll it might another very popular
thing is compression right this might
contain a flag which says that hey this
that this file is actually compressed or
in fact it's usually more complicated
than that it's usually like hey I'm
using type 4 compression or something
like that which means that this data
won't be in the right format until you
actually uncompressed those bytes okay
so compression is something that we
might go on to in the future just it
won't be part of game programming it
definitely won't be but it will
definitely be part of like Sparky or
something and we'll talk about that I
might make some videos on that and
whatnot but um for now all you need to
know is that this is the kind of
information lies in the header ok then
you have the data ok now the data is
essentially all of your actual data ok
so in an mp4 file for example it might
be each individual frame ok obviously
and before the compressed format which
would not have each individual frame as
like a pixel array or something they use
techniques for compression slashes put
like frame prediction and predicting
where movements gonna happen or what
pixels going to interpolate to where
anyway we're gonna get into that because
this
definitely not about that but the point
is this is where you have your actual
data okay so in our case this is where
we actually store stuff like hey we have
a variable called X this is value we
have a variable called name this is its
value all that stuff right we store that
in the data section and then we finally
have a footer now this is a lot of file
formats don't have this you don't
necessarily need to have this it's a
good idea for us to have it because it's
a good check to see if we've actually
received all the data we were supposed
to so this is almost like you could go
overboard here and you could be like
really paranoid and do something like
have a hash of the entire data at the
end there which would just mean you
would have like a long number
essentially which you generated by
reading the bytes that make up entire
data so this is like almost like a
checksum or sorry microphone this is
almost like a checksum which basically
says hey this is the dot this is the dot
this is like a string here that is a
bunch of numbers that I got from running
some mathematical like algorithms
essentially on the bytes here when I see
relized it doesn't match the DC realized
version right when I dislodge the data
and run the hash through the data it
does it is it the same are they equal if
they're not something went wrong maybe
some corruption occurred and what line
you could do something like that we're
not gonna do something like that because
it's not really that necessary all
they're going to do at the end is have
some kind of number which is like a
random number in fact we might just make
it like 1 2 3 4 or something which just
says that hey this is the end of the
file why would we have that well one
might argue that it's not too necessary
for files that are actually on disk
because usually you might wouldn't lose
half of them but for example if we end
up if if our data ends up being split up
into multiple packets when we send it
over the internet or over the network
it's a good way of saying that hey we
didn't drop any packets like hey we
didn't we actually arrived with the
correct information like this is the end
of D this is the end of the file we got
all of it now because if it contains
these bytes at the end
that means that you know it's assembled
correctly and that is indeed the end
there is not more to come okay so you
might do something like that and we'll
probably just do something like that
just to demonstrate the purpose of the
foot and whatnot okay cool so anyway
that's a brief overview that's a brief
overview over the format of our ization
thing we're going to talk about a very
high-level version of that okay in the
next video I'm actually going to take
you guys in and we're going to start
probably structuring this format and
talk about the like pretty much byte by
byte what the what the format's gonna be
okay but right now we're just kind of
focus on a high level format because
we're pretty much out of time so this is
going to work we're going to have our
head off now the header is really going
to be just we'll talk more about what is
in the header next time because I don't
really want to talk about that now but
all you need to know is we have the head
of okay once we finish the header we
have our actual data now the data is
basically going to be an array of
so-called objects okay so objects are
essentially pictured them like you would
picture objects in any object-oriented
programming language such as Java right
so an object is usually something which
contains a bunch of variables of
different types and it is essentially
something that describes something right
so for example an entity would be an
object okay so that being said what do
we have inside an object and really what
we've got is an array of objects that's
what this entire format oil down to okay
and we'll talk about what encloses this
whole thing as well in a minute so these
objects what do they have well there's a
terrible error I'm going to control said
that that's even worse anyway so an
array of objects what our objects
contain objects will essentially break
down into a bunch of fields now we know
that fields are essentially you know I
guess class members right they are
things like you know X Y a flourish you
know a name all that stuff those are the
fields that belong to the
object so in this case the object is
entity okay and then these things are
actually the fields right so objects are
made up of fields okay and fields are
essentially as I said they're usually
just something like they've they've
always got a name they have to have a
name that describes what the field is
actually called so for example X would
be an example of that and then they have
data so they're kind of stored as key
value pairs okay obviously they have to
store information about type and whatnot
and we'll talk about that next time but
that's basically all you need to know
for now okay so we have an array of
objects and each object of course has an
array essentially an array of fields
okay and that's pretty much it that's
that's the basics of the minimum stuff
that we need in this realization format
we're going to talk about some more
stuff that we have as well for what not
now fields actually also contains
something which is just really a data
structure called a field definition the
reason is that when you think about this
and goodness me that's difficult to read
even for me let me just try that one
again from the top a field definition is
just basically a definition of how the
field is laid out so that's slightly
better I think so in field definitions
we would typically the reason the whole
field definition thing exists is because
we remember in pretty much any
high-performance serialization format
what we don't want to do is read the
whole thing into memory or even break it
up into arrays automatically okay so
what we could do when we dis turtle eyes
something like this is we could go
through we could loop through every
single object that is in the format
right we could loop through every field
that is in every object and we could
extract all the data pop it into its
like correct things so for example if we
have a number if we have a field that is
a string we could actually read the
bytes that make up the string put it
into an actual Java string and
and basically D sterilize the whole
format into memory straightaway and then
every field might actually allocate a
new byte array with the correct size of
what it has and it would read all the
batsmen file and suddenly we have this
entire destroys situation going on that
isn't exactly the opposite of what we
want to do okay that's not what we want
to do okay it might be what you want to
do and it might seem like a good idea
and it kind of might be for some
situations don't really but the idea is
that instead of doing that all we really
want to do is have kind of so-called
pointers and I don't mean literally kind
of like memory pointers although they
are kind of similar we want to kind of
have offsets I'm going to call them
instead of pointers we kind of want to
have offsets into the into the file to
be like hey if I'm actually interested
in reading this data this is the
beginning of it and I don't know how
long how big it is as well so in that
case we could actually extract that data
if we wanted to but the point is that
data is actually read on demand okay
it's not read immediately and by read I
really mean copied we don't copy the
data into memory like we might copy the
initial data structure into memory
because that's really the only way we're
reading it unless we're actually reading
it from disk byte by byte or we're
memory mapping it but we're not which is
basically the same by the way those two
things but in this case well Robbie just
copy the whole bite array into trouble
but we won't start copying it into sub
byte arrays for example until that's
actually requested from us okay because
that's that's a much that's been way
better for performance right we don't
want to just read our that we might
never even want to read as soon as we
request the data to be read that's
actually when we read the data yeah
makes sense right and that also is quite
efficient so that's the idea
okay so fuel definitions will have stuff
like it they might contain like
information about the field but they'll
also contain stuff like an offset for
example from the beginning of this
object or whatever into the actual bytes
that contain the data so that we can
rate them when we want to okay that's
the idea the other big thing that's
important is a raise okay now if we do
have an array and we actually will have
like
arrays are basically objects by the way
just with being able to contain fields
that essentially are arrays instead of
just primitive data so for example if we
were to have you know X Y that's fine
but if we were to have for example well
let's just say we want to copy every
single pixel and in in our screen so
that's like for a full HD monitor that
would be like 2 million pixels we want
to copy them in we want to sterilize
them just as a raw pixels ok right raw
integers we just want to sterilize them
right that would mean we would have to
create 2 million objects correct yes
correct
well sorry let me say that again we
could either create 2 million objects or
we could create two million fields but
either way we have to create these 2
million versions of these one of these
two right what that means is that we
have two million field definitions ok
and we have all the overhead that is
associated with with creating an object
with creating a field and with creating
a field definition in every single pixel
in every single one of those 2 million
things which is terrible for performance
it makes our file size probably 10 times
as larger that needs to be if not more
and it's really just very bad ok so in
those cases where we have so much to
serialize and we don't really care about
the data right we can just read all
those data and then read them right into
an array we don't care we don't need
each one of them to be named it's
essentially an unstructured kind of
object right if we are making something
like that and it's an array for example
we need to have a specialized kind of
object that is an array because what
this will have is a single field sorry
it might have multiple fields but every
field has to be an array right usually
you wouldn't do something like that but
what I'm saying is you would essentially
only have one field definition ok just
one all right and then that would tell
you how that that will probably be more
than just a regular field definition
really like I don't want you guys to
confuse fields and field definitions
with arrays because it'll probably not
have any of these I'm just kind of
trying to explain this better by using
those two but essentially all we need is
we need to know what type of data is in
the array it could also be an array of
objects but remember that's
kind of out here so they're really gonna
talk too much about that but it could be
it'll be essentially an array of of raw
data and then before that we have like a
little header for that that which
describes what the length of the array
is so how many elements are in the array
well the size of each element is what
type it is all that kind of stuff all
right and that is essentially how we do
a race now objects one more thing I want
to mention here is objects actually can
contain objects okay that's very
important stuff so we will sometimes
want like one of these fields it doesn't
just have to be raw data it could be
another object
another serialization object okay and
we'll talk about more about how that
kind of structure will come together in
the end there and you'll see it as I
write it but um it's not that
complicated okay
you can kind of think of this whole
system is almost like a key value kind
of thing okay with the exception of
things like arrays which just have like
a blob of like a binary blob of data at
the end of them okay cool anyway we have
all those DUP and then we have a footer
and as I said a footer is just going to
contain maybe like two bytes so 12 and
3/4 just in hexadecimal they kind of
line up like that and you could have
something like that and obviously this
isn't actually 12 it's 18 and decimal
but the point is you can do something
like that
for example just to be like oh hey I've
completed my thing all the data is
present it's in between the header and
footer you can read it now or something
like that okay so that is pretty much
the end of that that is a high-level
overview I thought how this data
structure is going to work and this
entire thing right so something that so
this has like a header or footer all of
that stuff which is actually the packet
that we want to send obviously we might
break this up into smaller packets
because it might if it's like over a
megabyte or something there's no where
we're going to send that as a single
packet we need to break it down and
we'll talk about that later that's more
of a that's more of a issue of actual
network communication than sterilization
but all of this we might write into a
file for example and that'll be one
thing this is called a data base okay so
a data base
contains a bunch of objects and arrays
and a header in Florida and that's
pretty much it
okay a database is just like a
collection of objects that's pretty much
it okay and this database is like a
single kind of sterilization file that
we write out or a packet that we send or
whatever but the point is if this entire
structure is a database okay and
database is ultimately where we query
and we get our bytes from and then we
know that the database bytes are
actually this entire thing okay cool so
that's gonna wrap up this video hope you
guys enjoyed next time we're going to
take a look at what exactly is inside
every object byte by byte so we'll
totally go through it make sure that we
understand exactly how it works and why
not and then after that I'm like yeah
they're gonna have to be a few videos
here that just kind of like talking
about stuff with this kind of me drawing
stuff for you I hope you guys enjoy that
by the way leave a comment below if you
are if you if you do or if you don't or
whatever or if you would rather I do
something differently but as soon as we
get past these things which are very
important we will actually start running
the format there's nothing worse there's
not much worse you can do really than
starting just coding like a mutilation
format without actually planning it out
paper first very important stuff because
um you'll you'll find yourself going
back and rewriting stuff all the time
and that's not that fun okay cool and
I'm also a big big fan of like just
planning stuff out on paper or on the
whiteboard so it totally works as well
so if you guys enjoyed this video you
can support me on patreon patreon
Lacombe for such the Turner link in the
description you can pledge a certain
amount per month and essentially you
will get rewarded for that so for
example for five dollars on the wall per
month you'll get access to the entire
source code of game programming on
github it's a private repository so just
if you do enjoy my videos and you want
to see more of them you can support me
here the more support I receive on here
it essentially translates into the more
time I can allocate into making videos
okay so it's really pretty simple you
know time equals money so that's how
that works
and again if don't feel obligated to
give at all right if you just want to
enjoy my videos and you don't and not
support me that's totally okay you can
just leave a like a like on this video
or a comment
something and that is honestly good
enough for me but for you guys who are
actually really enjoying my videos and
really want to you know for all of you
super fans out there it's a really good
way to support me and finally I did make
a slack channel I've actually got it
open here so this is an example of what
it looks like so like I've been I've
been talking quite a bit on here as you
can see and people have just been doing
about stuff there are channels for like
C++ Java you know and programming Sparky
all of that kind of stuff
and random and you can see that it's got
like 94 people that I subscribed or that
have joined the team so far so I think
we can defer get that to 100 but like
tonight but um it's a it's a cool little
community where you can just as you can
see you can kind of just chat in real
time to people all the time
right and I'm usually on this as well
pretty often because my phone is hooked
up to this so every time you guys say
something I get a notification which is
fantastic but that's how that works link
in the description you can sign up on
slack top the trio comm and then finally
the actual slack page is the Turner
don't slack comm just reversed pretty
cool but anyway if you guys enjoy this
video please hit like button and I will
see you guys next time with the next
episode of this civilization miniseries
good bye